all right so I'm just gonna say it the
She-Hulk attorney at law finale slapped
yes it did it did prove me wrong or
don't even try it whatever the Disney
plus series brought every threaded
needle throughout his first season
together in a ninth episode that
included some predictable hulking
moments and it also had that amazing
opening sequence that mirrored like the
original Incredible Hulk series from the
70s mwah
all right we got all our favorite guest
stars back Blonsky Titania Wong
Daredevil of course but there was one
major moment that everyone's talking
about
uh Jen I could use a whole Council here
Welcome to My Life
hey everyone
[Music]
cousin Bruce I know I've been away once
a car for a while I'll tell you all
about it but first
I have someone here that I'd like you
all to meet
this is my son scar
[Music]
oh
wow your family
yeah big moment
I finally got Charlie Cox back as
Matthew Murdock in a relationship now
with Jennifer Walter She-Hulk okay
there's a lot to break down here what is
happening there's a sun involved has a
sun now aside from the fact that no one
in the Walters family saw a giant hulk
behind Hulk right like which is like did
he sneak through the bushes I don't know
but it works for me because it's too bad
scar yeah the existence of Scar one of
Hulk's Sons is a big deal for Comic fans
like me right who have always wanted a
World War Hulk Planet Hulk storyline to
happen in the MCU There's a comic book
thing okay I asked Mark Ruffalo about
this ages ago when I was interviewing
him uh maybe for I can't remember one of
the Avengers movies or for Ragnarok but
there's a big story line and he's kind
of always said that he would love to but
I don't know if there's another Hulk
movie coming or this and that if you
could if you could imagine him being on
his own again what would you love to see
him do in his own movie well the big
thing we were
I was was loving to see was was um
having
um him do Planet Hulk yeah and and we
kind of get to do this yeah what when I
went to I went to Marvel I went to Kevin
he said if you got to do a standalone
movie what would it be
and I spit out yeah what I thought it
could move would be he said why don't we
do that but spread it over three movies
so we'll start in Thor three okay we'll
carry it on to Avengers three and finish
it in Avengers 4. and we'll do that
character Arc that you're talking about
but the idea that scar exists it's kind
of like a glimmer of hope for people
that this super epic storyline where
Hulk has uh lived on sakar has father
two sons with another amazing Warrior
named kyera and there's a tragedy and
all this that this could come to pass
now he was already on sakar in Ragnarok
okay and it was you know it was fun it
was played for laughs but clearly
there's a lot that we don't know that
they are going to include in the MCU so
I'm very excited for this why the name
Scott
well it's from he's like like the scar
the planet's scar
right it's a lot you kind of have to
read I'll lend you the comics if you
want you've got a lot of time right